for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
university comm thank you and enjoy so
first up we're gonna learn how to name
ionic compounds and specifically the
three subclasses we're gonna name my
onic compounds with monatomic ions and
we're gonna learn how to name ionic
compounds with metals or more than one
ion and also the ones from polyatomic
ions okay now they're all really the
same thing but I split it up just to
make things simpler okay now the general
rule with all of them though is that we
name the cation first and then we name
the anion second okay that's for all
three cases okay so let's start off with
the ionic compounds from monatomic ions
for the cation what you do is you simply
name the metal name the metal and then
for the anion the nonmetals ending is
changed to ID right you have the
elements element names root ending with
ID okay so let's do a couple examples
here name the ionic compound that would
form between the two listed elements
magnesium and fluorine well magnesium
would be the metal right magnesium as a
metal and therefore it would be the
cation right and fluorine is the
nonmetal and therefore it would be the
anion so for the cation I would just
name the metal okay so that would be
that means that would be magnesium the
name would be magnesium something what
am I getting - well the for the anion
that's gonna be the fluorine the
nonmetals anything's gonna be changed to
ID so fluorine would be fluoride so
magnesium fluoride would be the name of
that compound that forms between
magnesium and fluorine okay what about
the one that forms between sulfur and
strontium well sulfur is a nonmetal I'm
just gonna be Viet as an M so that would
be V anion and then strontium is the
metal I'm gonna abbreviate that as M and
that would be a cation so for the cation
I just name the metal right so that'll
be strontium
strontium and the anion is gonna come
from sulfur and that would be sulfide
right so strontium sulfide would be the
name of the ionic compound that forms
between those two elements yeah now what
about their chemical formulas well if I
think about magnesium fluoride we're
gonna have magnesium ion mg 2 plus and a
fluoride f- right these are ions that
have had to have had memorized right and
so I'm just gonna do the crisscross
method right this number goes here as a
subscript and this number which is not
explicitly listed as a 1 right that's
gonna go here right but ones are not
explicitly written so that would just be
mg 1 but no subscript actually written
mg F 2 okay and then for strontium
sulfide strontium is SR 2 plus right and
sulfide is s 2 minus so crisscross right
this number goes down here this number
here kind of covered up that 2 there so
that would be SR 2 s 2 but this is an
ionic compound and we write things as as
the lowest whole number ratio between
the two ions so it's actually gonna be
SR s right that'll be it there right and
then mg F 2 for the previous one okay
now since we're talking about a crystal
array of many ions we we don't have a
molecule right we have we've got formula
units that we're talking about here
formula units which give us the ratio of
cations to anions in the crystal right
so here we got the ratio of 1 to 2 for
magnesium fluoride and one to one for
strontium sulfide now strontium sulfide
this lowest whole number ratio what type
of chemical formula is that well it's an
empirical formula as we learned in the
video about the different types of
formulas it's an empirical formula in
fact nearly all
ionic compounds have empirical formulas
as representing their formula unit okay
there are a couple exceptions one
example of a type of exception is
compounds with the mercury 1 ion okay
which is the HG 2 2 plus right and so
the correct thing if we had mercury or
mercury 1 ion with with fluoride for
example we'd have HG 2 2 plus and F
minus 1 right so this would go here and
this would go here right and now in that
case we would imagine putting
parentheses around that to put the 1
there but since the 1 is not going to be
explicitly shown we don't need to put
that that's what we end up getting is HG
2 F 2 that would be correct
now we don't simplify this because it's
not actually just hg + 1 right so we
don't get we don't get this that's wrong
it's hg 2 F 2 so in that case that's an
exception to this idea of the empirical
formula rule okay another example is
alkali metal peroxides
okay now peroxide peroxide is o2 2 -
okay and the same idea though right if I
have sodium and peroxide sodium ions na+
1 and peroxide is o2 2 - if I
criss-cross right put that 2 there and
that one outside there the 1 doesn't
have to be explicitly written that would
be an A - OH - but I can't simplify this
because it's not just an O minus 1 ion
right it's a no - 2 - so this would be
correct instead of this okay I hope that
makes sense that's a little bit kind of
messy but I hope that makes some sort of
sense ok next step
ionic compounds with metals that form
more than one ion ok now if you recall
metals are for more than one ion have
systematic names as well as common names
so we're gonna show both here so the
system for systematic naming for the
cation you're gonna you're gonna
basically put the metal name followed by
parentheses with the Roman numeral with
the charges magnitude okay and then for
the anion you're just gonna have the
nonmetal ending with ID right okay so
for example if I have Fe 2 plus and Cl
minus I'm gonna have this to go here the
one go here and I'm gonna get fecl -
that's my formula so that is a
combination of iron two right here okay
so that's gonna be iron our parenthesis
with the Roman numerals iron - and then
the CL minus is chloride so it's gonna
be iron two chloride right because the
nonmetal ending has to be ID okay and
for fe 3 plus Fe 3 plus that's iron 3
right and we still have pull right here
so fecl3 would be the the formula there
and so the name would be iron 3 chloride
okay now for common naming that's gonna
be a little bit different obviously the
real difference though it's gonna be
coming from what's gonna be going on
with the name for the cation okay the
anion will be named in the same way you
just add the ending ID to the nonmetal
okay so it's a matter of what we write
before that so for the cation you have
the common name ending with owe us for
the charge with the lower magnitude
right and then the one ending with IC
for the higher magnitude of charge
okay so Fe 2 plus is fair us right and
then after that we just put chloride
alright Fe 3 plus is fair Rick and then
we just put chloride right so fe co 2 is
either iron ii fluoride or
ferrous chloride both of those names are
correct and fecl3 is iron 3 chloride or
ferric chloride again both are correct
but I care more about systematic naming
I'm probably gonna use this more often
than the common naming common naming is
kind of wack anyway so let's do an
example here what's the chemical formula
for a lead to oxide well what I would do
is go from this name immediately writing
the actual ions right what is led to
well lead to is PB 2 plus and I just
have memorized right what is oxide oxide
is o2
- so crisscross method this number goes
here this number goes here so that's
gonna be PB - OH - but then I'm gonna
get the empirical formula right lowest
whole number ratio of these ions that
would be PB OH
so that would be the chemical formula
for lead to oxide okay what would it be
what would be the name of Cu 2 O what is
Cu 2 O and I look at this I look at Cu
and I recognize okay see you that's a
transition metal and that can have more
than one charge so I don't know which
one that is
immediately well I do but I've studied
this countless for countless hours but
when you look at this right you look at
the the metal and you realize that I
could have more than one charge you use
the the nonmetal to help you figure out
what that metal is charge was okay so
oxygen I know that oxygen as an anion is
oxide and that always has a minus 2
charge let o is an O 2 - so what did
this see you had to have what what must
that have been if this is the F formula
that resulted well that's the formula
that resulted what I could do is kind of
work backwards with a crisscross method
this 2 must have gone up here and this
one must have gone up here so the two -
right that's this - could become the two
- on oxygen what must have been the
charge of copper in order to yield this
particular chemical formula well in
order to get that copper must have been
plus one right because if I do the
crisscross method now right then I get
Cu - oh right
so I know I know then that it's C
you plus one right and so that is copper
one right so this would be copper one
and this Oh two - is oxide so copper one
oxide which of course copper there's
copper one there's also copper two right
copper two would have been Cu two plus
right and just to kind of show you over
here that could have been Cu two plus
and OH two - that would have ended up
being Cu 2 O 2 which of course was
simplified down to Cu OH
and so that's the formula that we would
have had if it was copper two oxide but
that's not the case here okay so it
could have been this is I could name
this as copper one oxide right that
would be correct
but if I'm using common naming then that
would be cuprous oxide right again I
don't really like common naming but that
would be the correct common name okay
all right let's move on to ionic
compounds that are coming from
polyatomic anion or sort polyatomic ions
okay so for this for the cation you
basically use what you've learned from
the previous two situations right if
it's a simple monatomic cation you name
it according to that if it's a if it's a
monatomic cation that can form more than
one ion then you use what you learn
there
however this little asterisk here and
the the only time you don't use what you
learn from the previous two situations
is is unless the cation is a polyatomic
cation right which there again there are
a few of them in that case if you have a
polyatomic cation all you would do is
you would just name the polyatomic
cation poly atomic okay and then for the
anion right which most of the polyatomic
ions are anions you would simply name
the polyatomic anion right according to
its actual name okay so if we have na
plus and no.3 - we've got na plus this
is sodium right and we've got no.3 -
here we
should have memorized that name is
nitrate okay and the formula if we do
the crisscross method we get nano3 so
what is the name of nano3 nano3 is named
sodium right we're using what we learned
from that's the first section and we're
for the for the anion we're just gonna
name the polyatomic anion which is
nitrate so that is sodium nitrate what
if we have magnesium right with the plus
2 and we have no.3 minus right so now
it's just magnesium oops
magnesium all right and then we just
name the anion nitrate and you'll notice
here with this formula that has
parenthesis in it why does it have
parenthesis in it the reason why is
because when you do the crisscross
method here this 2 goes out here and
this one goes here right when that 2
goes out there that that's two it's two
of these entire nitrate ions right it's
it's the entire nitrate ion that has
this negative charge so if I have plus
two a charge of plus two coming from
just the single magnesium then I need
two of these entire and no.3 minuses
right I need add those two of these
negative charges to balance out with
that one positive two charge from
magnesium so I can't just put the the
two on the unjust I can't just write it
as mg no.3 - that would mean 32 oxygens
which is not right I'm when I put those
parentheses there when I put the
parentheses here I'm implying that there
are two of these nitrates right so
that's the idea of the parentheses there
and that's something you'll have to pay
attention to when you do a lot of work
with these polyatomic ions okay so let's
go through a name some of these a B and
C so we've got Fe and then front the CCL
o33 so what is this I'm going to split
it up into its ions I know that Fe is
iron but I don't know if it's iron 2 or
ion 3 okay but if I look at this I look
at clo3 and I know that's chlorate
because I had
memorize that so I know that I have an
iron ion and it's either a +2 or a +3
and then I have the CLO 3 and I know
that that's chlorate and it has clo3 -
so in order to get that 3 right here
that must have come from the iron and
that's an iron 3 right so I've got iron
3 here and I've got chlorate so what's
that going to be that's going to be iron
3 chlorate that would be the name there
or the common name ferric chloride okay
all right next one BA right with this C
2 H 3 o 2 and there's two of those okay
so I know that BA is barium and barium
always has a +2 charge right and that's
where this came from so BA 2 + and then
I have the actually I will get rid of
those pluses BA 2 plus and then I have
the C 2 H 3 o 2 I should have memorized
that as acetate right that's C 2 H 3 o 2
and that has a minus 1 charge okay so
I'm going to name the cation which is
just barium in this case and the anion
is just the name of the polyatomic anion
which is acetate so barium acetate and
that's it for that one next one
I've got sodium there sodium is always
na plus hco3 I know that to be hydrogen
carbonate or bicarbonate so this can
either be sodium hydrogen carbonate or
sodium bicarbonate right both are
correct so now you'll also come across
some some problems like this sometimes
they'll ask is is the following
correctly named right and if not
corrected so let's look at this first
one so this first one we got ca no.3 -
right so CA that's definitely calcium so
that part looks okay to me
I should split these up into its ions
that would be CA 2 plus right and we
also have the no.3 that's - that's
nitrate so it says calcium nitrite okay
that's a problem okay because so this is
definitely not correct right so the
answer here is no and that's it's simply
because this is not this no.3 minus is
not nitrite its nitrate so the correct
name would be calcium nitrate and that
would be correct
all right Part B B we have K that's
potassium ion so k plus a so for that is
sulfate so4 - - okay so the name there
should be potassium okay and then
sulfate now this one's this one's got
something wrong with it because this one
is shown here explicitly in Romanova
that's right and as potassium one
sulfate that's not supposed to be there
because with potassium there is no
ambiguity there it's always plus one so
you don't have to explicitly label that
so that's not correct instead it's just
potassium sulfate potassium sulfate
would be the correct name for that okay
now this one we got al that's aluminum
aluminum has a plus three charge Oh HOH
- that's hydroxide okay so aluminum
would just be named aluminum parts right
hydroxide is the name of the polyatomic
ion aluminum hydroxide yeah that one's
correct that one doesn't have you
changed okay I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying